[Music]
it's a really interesting organic writer
process I wrote an outline foreign
breakable it included Kevin Wendell
crumb so essentially the movie split and
unbreakable word the same movie and they
were they were very much the same and
they abduct three girls
while David survives this crash and it's
told hey I think you're super here we
keep cutting to this storyline with the
girls and they're being held here and
the multi multiple personalities and I
see the Beast is coming the Beast is
coming meanwhile he's like no I'm not a
superhero no I'm not a superhero then he
goes maybe I am meanwhile the Beast is
coming beast is coming then he goes
maybe I am and he goes to the train
station and bumps into the horde and
gets the vision of the girls and follows
them back follows him the Beast and then
the beast in him fight in that big
moment and at the end of the original
unbreakable and so you remove that for
balance I read is that yeah you know I
all I wanted to do I the moat thing I'm
most interested in is the first act of
movies that's the thing I'm always
interested I know everyone's interested
in the third act but I'm really
interested in the first act of this set
up and so I really wanted to make the
movie you know when I think about this
my favorite show The Sopranos I think
you know maleeh interesting thing about
that is it's about the home life of what
it's like to be the head of the Mafia
you know and what it's like to go home
and what is that can you be a human
being and all those struggles and this
is that this is yes these are comic-book
movies but it's really about what it's
like to be a regular person and somebody
that has these powers and to do that I
had to take Kevin out of it cuz all you
wanted to do is be with Kevin as soon as
you start that ticking clock with the
girls you can't stay away from it you
have to go back quickly you have to
so it started putting this enormous
pressure on the character that I wanted
to build so I took him out and made the
movie just about Elijah and David and
then what I guess what happened is the
movie type of movies that I was making
changed in recent years I wanted to make
contain smaller movies that I could
control and I can make them as weird and
really signature and take a ton of risks
and when someone says that'll never work
perfect put it back to put it in you
know and so I made the visit
that way and then I and I said you know
what the next movie you know I could
make split I could make that second
movie and what what would happen if we
never told anybody we were making a
sequel and we didn't sell it that way
and we just made it and put it out and
only in the last moment told them hey
guess what we're making a trilogy you
know and so that was that was the
exciting idea behind it and James he
told me he met him at a comic-con party
and he said he was off his nut drunk is
that true and why was he the person to
play Kevin well I did yeah what's really
interesting right that I mean the lead
of my comic book movie at Comic Con
which is what happened I mean we were at
an event and he walked by me and and I
was like oh why hey man and I just
grabbed his arm and it's like hey he
goes hey and we never met before and I
said oh I'm a fan of yours and he said
I'm a fan of yours and he had come back
from x-men and so his hair was growing
back from being shaved and it was kind
of like I'm inch long or maybe a 3/4 of
an inch long and I was like staring at
him as he's talking and I was had
written split and the first time I
checked he was unavailable but I was
staring on and I'm like this is the guy
and I was like this is the guy this is
what the guy should look like he
shouldn't even do any wigs no makeup
just let him do this and change
personalities and just like amazing
things happen his movie went away and he
became available and I sent him the
script and he was like oh my god and
here we are got in touch sent me the
script I asked him a few questions about
one of the questions I usually ask is
what character is that you're looking
for me to play because I don't like
reading a script and I don't know which
character is because there may be two or
three that you'd be right for and you
get attached to the wrong one or
whatever and then they're like oh no
it's for the other guy and you're like
um baby to that question he just said
just read a you'll see it's a lot just
go with it and turn the first page I'm
like oh wow that's going in the second
page and I'm like wow something
different and then I get start to
understand the complexities of the fact
that the complainant character with the
ID and just how many characters I'll be
playing and I just saw it as a really
interesting opportunity to explore the
ID and also just a huge challenge and
that something that
I was looking forward to the times yeah
I enjoyed playing Patricia she's there's
something slightly repressed and kinky
about her I enjoyed playing Hedwig
because he was so free and yet so
vulnerable at the same time and that's a
nice contradiction that that allows for
a lot play as an act that I mean who's
the hardest I don't know I think the
hardest defined was Hedwig I couldn't uh
you know Anna Dortch a guy who's 37 at
the time I think I was um
pretending to be 9 years old is
potentially unwatchable and even if it
is watchable it might not be watchable
for more than half a minute before you
go out I don't know if I watched too
much more of this that was tricky and I
wasn't really getting a handle on it and
then night came along and said why don't
you try it with a lisp and I was quite
resistant to that so I was like I don't
know man's like kids got enough going
against them at the moment and you know
and I don't know I just felt yeah I
don't know what nothing has anybody with
less but it felt that we were just go
and I don't know just he's already so
idiosyncratically different from
everybody else they why it's fairly -
much better as soon as we did it what
and it felt really right and real the
crew would start clapping on split
whenever he finished because we knew we
were watching something extraordinary
the other actors as well they would
shake their heads because we you know
when an actor's in the pocket and when
they're doing something extraordinary
that's happening in front of you like
you can't believe it that it's just
alive and it's really working and it's
you know it's come to life in front of
you and he was doing that with these
characters and I know I've multiple
times I went to him and I go I don't
understand there's maybe five people in
the world that could even try to do what
you're doing right now and you're doing
it
and you're doing it effortlessly and I'm
like you need to be doing the best roles
the hardest roles in the world because
you know I what you're doing is is an
astonishing and and so we did know what
was happening
[Music]